voting rights advocates warned the
kentucky primary was a recipe for
disaster
with a shortage of poll workers the
state slashed the number of polling
places from 3 700 to just
200. there were serious concerns that
the pandemic era restrictions would
suppress the black vote
instead election officials are expecting
near record turnout
especially in louisville's parent
jefferson county the county received 218
thousand requests for mail-in ballots
several times the usual
number this has been the largest primary
in
jefferson county's history by ballot
request
and of course today's been a decent
turnout as well
and the six days that we had prior to
this
for voting here yesterday we ended the
day with 11
111 people the kentucky exposition
center the state's largest voting venue
never reached capacity here in
louisville
elections usually have 200 polling
places but now
there's just this one for a county with
more than 600 000 registered voters and
that includes half of the state's black
population so the concern
was that african-american voters would
be under counted
because they'd be dissuaded from coming
to the polls by long lines
but somehow with early and mail-in
voting louisville
has avoided the kind of fiasco that many
had predicted
but you've got a vote a month-long delay
in the election and the recent police
killings of black americans has raised
the prospects of a black progressive to
challenge the most powerful member of
the u.s senate
for months charles booker's long shot
candidacy for the senate has been
eclipsed by his rival
former marine fighter pilot amy mcgrath
was considered
unbeatable the winner will run for the
senate seat held by mitch mcconnell the
republican leader
and could help the democrats take
control of the senate
it's extremely important to get mitch
mcconnell out he doesn't represent the
interests of not only kentucky
and louisville kentucky but the nation
but since the election was postponed in
may black voters have been
energized by the police killing of
george floyd
i like his platform i like what he
stands for
and his values are my values
as the last of these voters have filed
through in this extraordinary pandemic
year
the state of kentucky will have to
remain in suspense on the outcome until
june 30th
when the last of the mail-in votes have
been counted john hendren
al jazeera louisville kentucky